[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مو سكول النيتو هل تريدون حقا
صواريخ الروسيه تغتصب السماء الاوروبيه
وسلاح اوكراني يدخل الحرب ليغير مجرى
المعارك وقوات اوكرانيا تتقدم
دوله عربيه ورسميا طباخ بوتين يرفض اوامر
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه فكيف سيرد بوتين
والتنين الصيني ينفث لهيبه نحو كوريا
الجنوبيه وبكين تتجسس على الولايات
المتحده منذ مده طويله وتايوان تستعد
للحرب بطريقتها الخاصه واليابان تعلن
مواجهه صواريخ كيم والسعوديه تقول كلمتها
لتضرب بصوت عقابها الالمان والامريكان
واليابانيين معا في السودان تحطم الامل
مجددا والاسرائيليون يتعرضون لحادثه مؤلمه
اخرى على الحدود المصريه
روسي صاعق
ضجيج محركات النيتو لا يكفي توسع الحلف
باتجاه روسيا وضعت زيت بجانب النار ليذهب
اعضاء النيتو نحو اللهيب الروسي بالمنفى
وبعد ايام من تصريح الامين العام السابق
للنيتو
قد ترسل قوات الى اوكرانيا بشكل فردي جاء
الرد الروسي بتساؤل عفوي من نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي بمتر عما اذا كان سيؤخذ
برئيس سكان هذه الدول في مثل تلك الخطوه
تايلاند حسنا هل سالت سكان هذه البلدان من
منهم يريد الحرب مع روسيا هل يريدون حقا
ضربات تفوق سرعه الصوت على اوروبا وغيرها
بعيد عن مهاترات مع روسيا تواصل اوكرانيا
هجومها المبارك وهنا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه محاوله اوكرانيه لاستهداف سفينه
تابعه لاسطول البحر الاسود وتدمير جميع
الزوارق السته التي شاركت في العمليه
بينما اعلنت القوات الروسيه عن سد جميع
الهجمات المضاده الاوكرانيه على محوري
دونيسكو خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه وتدمير ثلاث
دبابات ليبارد ونظام دفاع جوي بريطاني من
نوع ستورم وكرد على الدفاع الروسي جاءت
دور على الاوكران حيث اعلنت كييف ان
قواتها احرز التقدما لعدد من المواقع
بالقرب من مدينه بخم تشرق البلاد ونجحت في
التقدم الى ما يصل الى 1400 متر في عده
مواقع من الجبهه لافته الى انها كبدت
القوات الروسيه خسائر فادحه ودمرت معدات
عسكريه في المنطقه نحن لا ناتي بشيء من
مخيلتنا اليكم المصدر
القياده العسكريه الشرقيه قال ان قواته
تحاول ضربات على العدو وقد نجحت في التقدم
مما يصل الى 1400 متر في عده مواقع من
الجبهالفتا الى انها كبدت القوات الروسيه
خسائر فادحه ودمرت معدات عسكريه في
المنطقه
لتضيف انها استعادت بلده بلاجو ديت نيل
الواقعه الشمالي ضخمه وانسحاب القوات
الروسيه منها لكن وبحسب التقارير الغربيه
فهذه التقدمات الاوكرانيه ليست مجديه
مقارنه بالدعم الغربي الضخم فكيف ترى
حكومات الغرب ذلك تاتي الاجابه من صحيفه
حيث اشارت الى ان الولايات المتحده
واوروبا يعتقدون ان الهجوم المضاد قد يصبح
نقطه تحول في النزاع ويعتمد الكثير على
النتيجه اي ان مستقبل اوكرانيا مرهون
بنجاح هذا الهجوم فما عاد الغرب يطيق
تكلفه الحرب الباهظه عليهم وعلى ذات
السياق عرض قائد القوات المشتركه الجيش
الاوكرانييف سلاحا مضادا للطائرات يطلق
عليه فيكتور
معدل اطلاق فيكتور حوالي 600 طلقه في
الدقيقه ويضرب الاهداف الجويه على مسافات
طويله بشكل موثوق كما ان السلاح سهل
الصيانه ويمكنه المناوره ومن السهل اخفاءه
في موقع اطلاق النار من جهتها عاده الدفاع
الروسيه لتعلن ان قوتك اذ تكبدت نحو 700
عسكري وعده دبابات اربع منها من طراز
ليوبارديل الالمانيه ورتلين من المدرعات
وكالعاده اليكم المصدر القوات الروسيه
قامت باخماد هذه المحاوله
واعاده الاعداء الى الخلف مع الحاق اضرار
جسيمه بالافراد والعتاد من بين العتاد
العسكري
مدرعات امريكيه
ودبابات ايضا على محور
محور اوجل داره كان هناك قتال عنيف وقصب
المدفعيه
الانذار معلنه حاله التاهب لغارات جويه في
العاصمه وجميع المقاطعات والمدن
الاوكرانيه هناك نشد الرئيس الاوكراني
وزيره تغير المناخ والبيئه الاماراتيه
مريم المهيري التي تزور كييف حاليا لدعم
صيغه السلام التي تروج لك
ليعلن الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان قادر عن تحرك
عسكري لقواته وذلك بتشكيل فوجين جديدين من
وزاره الدفاع احمد روسيا واحمد الشيشان من
مقاتلين ذوي خبره والذين سيذهبون قريبا
الى منطقه العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا وفق قوله ومن اوكرانيا الى روسيا
وبعد ان امر وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
جميع وحدات المتطوعين بتوقيع عقود
بحلول نهايه الشهر وهي خطوه قال انها
ستزيد من فعاليه الجيش الروسي ليرد قائد
مجموعه العسكريه بقوله ان مقاتله لن
يوقعوا اي عقد مع رافضا بذلك اي محاوله
بوزاره الدفاع لاخضاع قواته لسيطره
الوزاره وبالعوده الى قضيه تفجير سد كخوجا
قالت المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
وجميع التحصينات التي اقامت القوات
الروسيه عند الخطوط الاماميه للضفه اليسرى
من نار دينيبرو في خرسون مؤكده تراجع قوات
موسكو نحو 15 كيلومتر
بكين تكشر عن انيابها
بالقلم والمسطره يتقدم الصينيون بخطوات
هندسيه معتمدين على القوانين الفيزيائيه
كالعاده فلكل فعل رده فعل وهنا استدعت
بكينس فيرا كوريا الجنوبيه لدى
وقدمت له احتجاجا شديدا اللهجه ردا على
استدعاء سيؤول للمبعوث الصيني لديها نهايه
الاسبوع الماضي وعلى الطرف الاخر قالت
اداره
المتحده من قاعده في كوبا وذلك من قبل
تولي بايدن للرئاسه ولكن واشنطن ستواصل
العمل لتعطيل خطوات
التجسس الصيني مصدر قلق مستمر للولايات
المتحده اما في تايبه [__] القوات
المسلحه التايوانيه تدريبات عسكريه بحريه
في ظل تصاعد التوترات مع الصين حيث تمت
محاكاه ازمه رهينه في مدينه في الجنوب
جنودها سيكونون رهينه في حال اندلاع الغزو
الصيني هل هناك خيار
لدى اصحاب العيون الضيقه
الاحداث والتطورات
مددت وزاره الدفاع اليابانيه الى اجل غير
مسمى امرا بتدمير صواريخ كوريه شماليه او
شافيا لها حول وجود تهديد بالسقوط على
اراضي البلاد فرضت التجاره السعوديه
غرامات ماليه على عشر وكالات سيارات
المانيه وامريكيه ويابانيه وصينيه خالفت
نظام الوكالات ولائحته التنفيذيه ومنها
وكاله المانيه لم توفر قطعه غيار بمواصفات
فنيه خاصه خلال المهله المحدده شن الجيش
السوداني هجوما واسعا على جميع جبهات
القتال وقام بغارات جويه مكثفه على مواقع
للدعم السريع في مدن العاصمه الخرطوم
ليفيق السودانيون صباح اليوم انتهاء
الهدنه على اصوات الانفجارات والمدافع
والرشاشات حول محيط مدينه الفتحاب جنوبيه
ام درمان بعد حادثه الجندي المصري ثم سرقه
السلاح والنخيره اعلنت تل ابيب بانقلاب
حافله في صحراء النقب كانت تقل 19 جنديا
اسرائيليا اصيبوا بجراح مختلفه والبعض
منهم في حاله خطيره روسيا تطلق تهديدا
صريحا للنيتو برايكم هل يريدوا الحلف حقا
رؤيه ضربات بصواريخ موسكو الفرق صوتي
[موسيقى]